- OKAY, SO I CALL IT
"BOOZE CHESS."
I GOT THE COGNAC ROYAL
AS YOUR KING.
QUEENSLAND VODKA--
OBVIOUSLY, THAT'S THE QUEEN.
UH, OLD STEED WHISKEY.
THAT'S THE HORSE/CENTAUR GUY.
- OH. CHESSMATE.
- LET'S JUST DRINK.
WHOA! CHECK OUT THIS GUY.
- I DIDN'T DO IT.
DON'T ARREST ME.
- CAN I HELP YOU, OCIFFER?
- IT'S MY COSTUME
FOR THE POLE DANCING CLASS
I'M TAKING
UP AT THE REC CENTER.
- GOOD WAY TO MEET BABES.
- YEAH.
- IT'S A GOOD WAY
TO KEEP THE BODY IN SHAPE.
AND, YES, I HAVE MET
SOME FRIENDS--WHO ARE LADIES.
CHERYL, PENNY, LAURIE.
WE'RE ALL GONNA MAKE
HOMEMADE PIZZAS LATER.
- SOUNDS GOOD.
SO WAIT, EVERYONE WEARS
A COP OUTFIT OR WHAT?
- OH, NO, NO, NO, THIS IS JUST,
UH, SOMETHING FRESH
I'M BRINGING TO THE TABLE.
THINKING I MIGHT CHANGE
THE GAME THOUGH
AFTER THEY SEE
THIS LITTLE ROUTINE.
CHECK IT OUT.
BUCKLE UP.
FREEZE! I'M GONNA NEED YOU
TO SPREAD 'EM.
- I LIKE IT SO FAR.
[music starts]
- YEAH.
- OH!
- HELLO. WHOA.
- YO!
- YAH.
- OH.
- WAIT A SECOND.
WHERE'D I PUT MY--
OH, THERE IT IS.
EYES DOWN HERE, FELLAS.
EYES DOWN HERE.
- SERIOUSLY, DUDE,
YOU GOT A PRETTY GOOD DICK.
- ♪ S--S--STOP,
C--COME ALIVE ♪
♪ IT'S BEAT LIKE THIS
THAT MAKE ME SMILE ♪
- OH, GOT ME.
- OH!
- OH, YEAH.
NO, YOU DON'T NEED TO...
- ALL RIGHT.
- NEED TO...
- OH, YEAH, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT'S ABOUT.
"OFFICER."
"YOU'RE UNDER ARREST."
- HEY.
WHOA! THIS IS A CHESSBOARD!
HEY, WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A GAME1
- AH!
- ♪ PUT YOUR HANDS UP
- MY TEACHER SAYS IF YOU DON'T
SWEAT IN YOUR CRACK,
YOU'RE NOT DOING IT RIGHT.